bientôt monde c'est wifi et aujourd'hui
on s'étend sur 13 heures qui est sorti
en france hier soir à 18 heures j'avais
pas le temps de faire une vidéo hier
donc je la fais aujourd'hui nous games
est parti j'ai passé ouzou on avait joué
à la démo il ya très précisément sept
mois et ça s'annonçait être plutôt
épique ne soit pas effrayé d'ouvrir les
portes
j'ai bien lu conseil n'ait pas peur
c'est une femme à trois têtes d'attaqué
avec un kotor
alors du coup j'aimerais bien savoir
l'histoire parce que finalement dans la
démo derrière ça se met des mois on fait
ça après je dis ça je dis rien à envier
aux garçons on t'a vu on t'as plein
est-ce que tu es sûr qu'on est sur le
bon chemin
mam où je pense mais comment ça se fait
que la coup la route
et si désastreuse à et regardez qu'est
ce qu'il ya qu'est ce qui se passe en
maintenant ou [ __ ] en direct dans le
dans le délire à d'ailleurs fermé da et
la fraude la porte au nez ou pas c'est
génial
ok on est à oui effectivement le point
il est carrément pété en mille tonnes
comment il marche ce genre de robot quoi
une petite photo souvenir ya un petit
portrait of the year qu'est ce qui est à
toi c'est la dépression courtois là et
ça me gratte les boue et toi moi je
pense à mon copain qui est bateau à la
maison et toi moi j'ai d'abord cassé à
temps mais les témoins carrément
diffamer regarder tomber celle qui va
tous nous tuer en fin de compte twitter
est celle où toi toi tu cache quelque
chose
je sais que tu peux nous est derrière
nous en 2007 sort je suis sur le bon
dieu attend une seconde watts
dépêche toi oh ok d'accord un ovaire oh
[ __ ] à l'endroit et mega bloks r je
tiens à préciser toile et laisser genre
vite ou alors on les ignore et marchait
dans les fougères et cette femme a deux
ballons à la place des fesses
ok nous y sommes on est roi et s'ouvre
les deux autres ok on a dix minutes de
jeu on a déjà perdu deux personnes
attendait fait quoi ta mère donc le
reste du groupe est restée là-bas pour
réparer la voiture elle est la tanche
parce qu'elle attend ton copain ne
viendra pas je pense qu'il faut monte
monte monte jusqu'à ce qu'un événement
dramatique date faith je vous mets pas
tes muara ça doit être super ce
spectacle toi tu es la fille de la démo
donc je sais que tu vas être vraiment
celle où l'ennui on peut apprendre ce
petit vélo ridicule la [ __ ] venir deux
fois plus vite
elle me fait flipper regardée comme une
marge en plus on va la prendre en
flagrant délit en train de courir on est
encore en cours et là hop flagrant délit
elle a fait non c'est pas moi je ne
pouvais pas à la 17e cette école semble
être un endroit sûr baho - ouais mais
ils ont déjà perdu tout le reste du
groupe wab
asseyons-nous ici pour un instant ce
qu'elle oublie que ça me rappelle la
première fois qu'on s'est rencontrés tu
t'en souviens non on va aller on va
aller regarder intérieur watts mais
[ __ ] mais pour l'actuel ok ça marche
best cette fille est mort en bref la
fille aux cheveux longs qui me fait un
peu flipper était en train de parler du
temps qu'elle a passé avec le perso
qu'on joue et voilà elle à la nuit tombe
weight non mais attends mais ils font
tous plus près dans le jeu plus tard
elle est soit l'intérêt ils sont allés
dedans depuis un très long moment
on devrait probablement aller voir
c'était comme un musée de dengue fait
déjà nuit on a été là dans combien de
temps et william kane il ya quelqu'un
qui est resté bloqué dedans
non mais tout est glauque dangereux même
les persos conjugue chance et nous
rassure et me font flipper voyage et la
ldj fait tout bas il le cherche mais
[ __ ] il est où ian yan yan ou
yahia d'où elle fait quoi et me regarder
ce zombie
re belote
laura ling please wait d'accord on se
réveille on est enfermé elle tape
puisqu'elle est pas content avec ses
mains d'oeuvre alors je ne peux pas voir
les autres et la porte principale et
fermé fortement et doit avoir un chemin
ailleurs que dans cette pièce chez
russie a traduit jusque là je ne dirais
pas que c'est glauque au [ __ ]
maintenant je me suis fait trop les
attentions
c'est pour mon ca fait voter le paysage
pop michael il ya des portes en bas des
trucs non waouh [ __ ] elle m'a fait
flipper et 1 mais toutes les portes sont
verrouillées
ne vous inquiétez pas tout va bien se
passer cette cinématique hockey
téléphone qui vibre
numéro privé moi je raccroche cc66 alors
on vend tout de suite on téléphone mais
immédiatement
qu'est ce qu'il ya où les couloirs voile
avait les cheveux blancs la couette pour
que ses cheveux et clignote elle passe
de l'état jeune fille de 18 ans à l'état
grand mère de 70 ans
en l'espace de deux secondes et demi
près du vieux bruit watts mais c'est une
blague
photo au wat me fait penser pas
imputable singulier bon gars mais c'est
une blague ou quoi
c'est pourquoi j'ai pris en photo bien
sûr c'est la réveiller c'est bon c'est
une photo haute et n'a passé qu'une
photo on dirait que ça le sale énerve à
la puissance de la photo c'est sa barre
toi et ta queue en tire-bouchon bac et
je suis moi j'ai un iris von mon gars
étaient phone qui bug petit messi 6
comment t'appelles dites-moi qui a
personne au shoot s'il vous plaît je
supporte pas qu'on aille avec des gens
dans les toilettes dans les jeux
d'horreur way
oui bon on est des gens bizarres
jusqu'au bout what
qu'est ce que c'est que ça y'a un truc
qui marche ou sorte de fantôme qui
faisaient rares lemsyeh qui avec des
mouches pluie qui surfe idée que je
prends en photo fin c'est pourquoi pour
aller au bordel je sais que tu aimes ça
je sais que tu en veux c'est bon là on a
dégagé style ali nahdi mais voilà tu
t'en fous par là tu saute par dessus ça
et puis tu dégages sais pas c'est quoi
ça oh
pourquoi une chaise qui se cassent des
je m'approche cet objet dégage une
mystérieuse énergie sa marque qu'est ce
qu'on fait on met les doigts dans la
prise tout de suite allé en rien ça qu
on peut pas prendre de cinq mâts mais
attend elle un petit sac en bandoulière
elle va transporter quoi une canette là
dedans o o la clinique respire fort oui
je viens en paix je ne peux pas me
réveiller
ok notre coeur il se met à battre plus
fort
oh [ __ ] c'était nous dans soixante dix
ans là pourquoi on est un vieux screamer
d'une espèce de poupées pour inna
chantant criait à tout les coups elle me
suit j'ai plutôt par avec mesa ballons
de baudruche
je vais l'attendre ici j'apprends en
photos ces attentions bon et respond to
vaincra aux aléas les outils oui oui
mais non mais mais apparemment elle ne
craint pas trop les photos j'ai pas de
mode vidéo je suis désolé mais j'ai pas
pris les respawns auger le que le
premier mais bon c'est pas top
attendons la juste fait un tour là mais
non mais c'est quoi hop et un chat noir
photo protège-moi protège moins jeunes
char tu te dois de protéger protège moi
bordel
tom le chat ils sont bas les couilles
les médias stone à amel hôtel à des
bruits horribles quoi on dirait qu'on a
pris un ballon de baudruche qu'on les
cartes là les deux les deux côtés qui a
l'air qui fait mais c'est bon là un
[ __ ] mais justement en fait on
pourrait voir que dans appareil photo
d'accord chat noir où es tu es moi elle
aime bien un truc sur le volet je sais
que tu es proche tu ne prendra jamais
mon bébé jamais déjà je n'ai aucune
envie de prendre ton foutu bébé à tout
ce que je veux c'est me barrer de cette
école ramon ton bébé me permette de
m'échapper je m'en fous la sortie merci
chat noir
on peut vraiment compter sur toi et tu
montes pas ton cul pour voir si non mais
c'est quoi ça m'est revenue à l'endroit
de thaler en plus ouais en fait c'est
absolument rien de ce que vient de faire
un appareil photo une libellule
hop là c'est un truc que tu as le regard
d une sorte de fantôme qui bug a ici en
fille sylvie faucheux s'il revient la
hâte en mai contre trop vite le maillot
s'il court aux côtés du chêne bol puis
c'est sûr szajner tu vas aller aux
toilettes allez je trouve ça va te faire
plaisir à vas-y fonds se pense et je
vais après toi c'est mons mais tu mets
vaste mais près des bruits de piano un
peu un peu glauque
objectif d'aller y s il est un placard
fermé dans une des chambres
il doit sûrement y avoir quelque chose
d'important dedans d'accord j'ai compris
le délire vous voulez que je trouve une
clé et et six essais à la clé viens avec
moi
les spots prendre non mais pas comme ça
tout pour te prendre dans mes bras
laisse moi bien il n'est pas du tout du
tout coopératif
regardez le [ __ ] de voix car on vient
montre moi où est la clé où est la clé
c'est pas la meuf de 85 ans qui veut
nous attendait l cbc watts
qu'est ce qu'est le bois d'accord en
plus il a une grosse fuite dans le dos
apparemment ok ah d'accord même les
fantômes roth
après une heure de recherches intensives
oh oh oh oh j'ai love clé enfin tout ça
pour ouvrir une [ __ ] d'armoires si
seulement ils avaient pu aider petit
coup de poing comme ça avec ses mains
d'ogre dedans là pour le casser sa mort
évitait de galérer pendant plus d'une
heure c'est l'heure d'ouvrir une armoire
ce geste n'a jamais été aussi jouissif
que maintenant alors il ya quoi dans
cette armoire monga au final ce cas
remonte à une armoire en fait une sorte
de d'endroits veya glauque caché
d'accord je comprends bien ça fait
plaisir aux débats fantômes non qu'est
ce qui vous fait on prend une perruque
pour tuer du fantôme ou eux
ah oui c'est bon ah oui oya photo pas
faux double qui fait des blagues jeux
très bien caché alors qu'y at-il au laos
et cloud
oh quel est cet homme
faut qu'on le tue faut qu'on le tue le
irish cob de eli stone vite non watts et
sarah danse et sert à rien de danser où
est dieu
bah je te vois mon enfant non mais c'est
un poste en fait une sorte de buzz photo
normand ces trois coups là c'est 78 tu
ne comprends jamais les cheveux ma
chevelure et éternel pas comme des
perruques moisi fantôme avec ton bébé
est moi des poupées
elle doit couper les cheveux [ __ ]
[ __ ] j'ai dû perruque mais non mais
mais [ __ ] mais tout est là pour les
trois banques
photo ho non mais veulent tuer mais non
même à tuer une petite tape aux fesses
bon elle part sur les arts martiaux
s'est cisaillée quoi donc donc c'est un
fou un une sorte de shooting photos
billets gratuits pour se porter yes ok
elle part en steaks
moi je suis choquée moi mais je suis
choquée mais léger quoi juste un fantôme
qui essaient de me couper les cheveux
mais je suis choqué les jeux y as est
décédé regardez sa tête l'euphorie ni à
y acheter les coupes et les chauffeurs
et oui bon du coup est-ce qu'on va
contre ses ciseaux oyu fait d'accord
super bon ça suffit
j'en ai marre quoi et le bébé comme eva
le bébé allait venir oui bonne nuit
et voilà les gens c'est déjà fin de
cette première vidéo sur trading qui
sont ceux qu'on aime est un très très
bon jeu personnellement j'ai eu quelques
frayeurs il est vrai et je veux aussi
pas mal de galères il est vrai j'avoue
avoir adoré faire le dlc d'autres
l'instant nantis avec vous je n'avais
jamais vraiment fait de let's play et
j'ai pris bien goût en faisant ce fameux
dlc red hat fait partie des gros jeux
d'horreur qui vont sortir cette année
donc je me suis dit allez on y va on se
retrouve très bientôt pour le deuxième
épisode et pour toujours plus de j'ai un
truc dans la et pour toujours plus de
bêtises parce que vous aimez ça tu as
tout le monde puisse le fantôme qui
coupent
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
les